let's go back to Discord and hear from a
few more people
davidpakman.com slash Discord is the
place to go let's go to genio from
Chester I guess it's a very complicated
thing or uh I don't know which is the
name and which is the location Jenny
welcome
hi David how are you doing well
awesome great to speak to you again
um I just hopped on so I didn't have a
question ready
um
uh what do you think are you a fan a fan
of
um Sean King the activist no I'm not
oh what are your reasons for that I
don't want to make this a whole thing
um listen I basically
uh I I'm trying to figure out how to do
this without like saying things that
aren't public my understanding is that
there's a sizable grift going on there
and it's never been my sort of activism
that I've seen him engage in and
honestly I didn't think he was active
anymore I haven't heard anyone mention
his name for years I I mean maybe he's
still doing stuff but I thought that he
had kind of Gone Gone silent some years
ago
oh okay
um yeah he's on Instagram and you know
uh I don't think he's as big as he was
but um yeah that was my question for
today thank you so much love love your
show all right there goes Jenny oh
hopefully that doesn't get me into any
trouble who the hell knows these days
anything can get you into trouble why
don't we go next to John from Salt Lake
City Utah the uh center of the uh Church
of Latter-day Saints John welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
yeah so I just have one question uh what
do you think of the recent news that
apparently some Russian partisans
invaded a Russian city of Belgrade you
didn't see possibly that could have been
like our special forces in there or
maybe encouraging them training them
something like that I have not heard of
that at all I'm going to have uh to to
research that
um I what when did this happen
this was like I think it was yesterday
or the day before jeez no I haven't seen
that yet and so the idea is that it may
not be what it actually appears to be
yes well what I'm thinking is maybe they
got training from like NATO forces in
order to do something like that or like
they're like directly involved in a way
you get what I'm saying
um that's interesting so what I'm
reading is
it seems Russia has not invaded But
rather
uh belgarad the Russian border region
was attacked by an armed group Crossing
from Ukraine there's a couple sources
saying that Russia accused Ukraine of
being responsible Ukraine Ukraine denied
it and said the attackers were Russian
citizens from paramilitary groups that
oppose Putin it seems we really don't
know right now what the truth is that's
what I'm gathering John from what the
pictures that I've seen it looks like it
could have been equipment that we
donated I saw a couple Humvees in there
yeah listen that's so speculative I just
don't know I would be cautious about
making it a definitive statements right
now I'm not sure you know I mean I don't
want to literally like pop on one bad
wagon the other I just want to like see
a little bit more details you know what
I'm saying yeah yeah I want to know the
truth of what happened from what I'm
seeing I'm looking at five sources and
they don't agree on what happened right
now
yeah all right thank you very much all
right I appreciate it yeah we're gonna
have to look more into that maybe by
next week we'll have uh more more
information but that's that's quite a
wild situation let's go to Brett from
Chicago Brett welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
hey Ava can you hear me yes I can
yeah yeah I'm glad to uh report from a
winning part of the country in a few
different ways I mean we just got the
most Progressive mayor in history
elected here true and I'm also
originally from Minnesota and a lot of
great things I don't know if you've been
hearing about that a lot of it great
things been coming out of like the
Minnesota Legislature recently I heard I
heard some we covered one story uh yeah
I mean so you're feeling good about the
part of the country you're in it sounds
like
yeah yeah honestly I'm a member of the
local um ydsa here you know the
Democratic socialists of America and we
were pretty excited we didn't endorse
Brandon Johnson directly because he's
not like a socialist but pretty heavily
uh I think he got support from our
sector a lot of the activity going out
and doing work on the ground canvassing
talking to people at polling stations
and that sort of thing so Brett as a Dev
as an actual Democratic Socialist
yourself I'm curious do you align with
the Socialist perspective of uh
socializing ownership of businesses like
is that something businesses should be
required to do by government
um I'm I'm definitely on the I guess
you'd call it the more conservative side
of the democratic socialists it's a
pretty big tent party as far as like
current like practical uh boots on the
ground activism like what we're active
on what we are um advocating for isn't
like
you know is it isn't normally that uh
extreme like
turning all businesses into co-ops
immediately through an executive order I
mean a lot of people again in the
organization would disagree with me on
that yeah yeah no I'm just asking you
like what would be your biggest
socialist belief would you say
yeah I would say that like I would be in
favor of things as straight as Extreme
as probably like breaking up large
corporations uh making more things like
publicly
not you know publicly uh owned like re
like d private deprivatizing like
infrastructure things like that I mean
like start with like the big things
where it seems very reasonable that you
and I would probably agree on like
public transport or yeah you know things
that like other countries socialize and
socialize well yeah and then I would
just probably keep moving forward on
that until it stops being effective but
so are you sure you're a socialist
that's interesting it's not I mean
there's your it sounds like you're more
of like a Social Democrat which is a
form of capitalism
yeah yeah I mean in the midterm it seems
to be that way but like I would like a
like having the means of production
being socialized being out like large
Industries being collectively owned that
seems like a good thing to me it's just
how we get there like social democracy
like I'm an electoralist I'm a you know
slow gradual movement so in the in the
short to medium term I do look
effectively like a a Social Democrat so
your view is sort of like that espoused
by Ian vausch the streamer where he says
in the immediate really socialist and
social Democrats probably would agree on
the same policies it's just that if they
were achieved then the Socialists would
want to go further yeah oh gosh I'm
getting out of here for agreeing with
Bosch so that's gonna be that's gonna be
great if this ever lies away because a
lot of people in the the DSA are not uh
not fans of his they're anti-vouch
that's interesting yeah there's a big
anti-vous movement probably a big anti
David packman movement as well oh
obviously listen there's no doubt
there's an anti-david packman movement
among the Socialists that's that's
without a doubt but uh yeah before you
before you let me go David I've gotta I
I should like represent that I am more
left in a way and actually ask you a a
somewhat difficult question or at least
it might it might not be difficult okay
please uh because you get a lot of
criticism from the left specifically on
uh your coverage of South America and
like Latin American politics I'm sure no
I mean I only I know years ago something
about Bolivia but I didn't know that
that was like an ongoing thing oh okay
so maybe you're not okay so there are
like a few things it's not like massive
but uh like I wonder if you have any
updates on that one story you covered
because you got some heat from that in
my circles anyway when you covered uh I
believe it was an Argentina there was an
assassination attempt and the way you
presented it was you were like very
suspicious of it and like it's kind of
suggesting that it may have been
something like a false flag or you know
like that it wasn't a real assassination
attempt and this was pretty like
immediate after the uh oh no I think I I
mean that was a while ago I don't know
if I didn't speak clearly or if maybe
you're misremembering it or I am but it
was more the idea that these that sort
of hijinks is the stuff I wouldn't put
past Christina but I was very very clear
that it was not uh something I was
asserting took place or I mean I was
super clear that it's merely speculative
and that there are people wondering
about it but that it was such an you
know uh offhanded thing I wasn't putting
a lot of stock in it I wasn't trying to
convince anyone of that I mean no it was
just it was just a you know it's just
casual conversation
oh okay okay fair enough yeah some
people get uh pretty antsy about like
that sort of speculation with you know
because people are a fan because they're
like the what the slightly more left
party and yeah country like Center left
I mean listen I'll be honest what I can
tell you is I think Christine is
completely out of her mind I mean cuckoo
for Coco Puffs I don't know if you've
been following her recently but seems
completely disconnected from reality but
that's probably a story for another day
uh okay sure enough well thank you much
very much for having me on David all
right Brett from Chicago worried about
uh worried about agreeing with Ian
vausch uh hopefully he doesn't get in
trouble